- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained, long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
- [Naomi] I'm often told that my talks are
very depressing. So I'm pleased to follow
Liz Hadley who's talk was even more
depressing than mine. If we didn't already
have enough to worry about, now we have to
worry about armadillos carrying leprosy.
So I was given an assignment for this
meeting and it was a very upbeat question:
will we survive the future? So I'm happy
to say that I actually have a positive
answer to that question. The answer is
yes. I do believe we will survive. As Liz
just showed us, we're a much greater
threat to other species than other species
are to us. And short of a meteorite impact
hitting us, I think that the odds that
humans as a species will survive are
probably very great at least for the
foreseeable future. It seems to me the
more relevant question though is how will
we survive and particularly in what
condition. Anthropogenic climate
disruption and its companion threat of
ocean acidification threatens to reverse
the developmental gains of the past 50
years decreasing the quality of life in
wealthy nations and pushing still more of
the world's poor as well as other species
to the edge of survival. The president of
the World Bank, Jim Yong Kim has recently
noted that climate change is a fundamental
threat to development. One that threatens
to reverse 50 years of progress. So what
will a future of unmitigated climate
change look like? Not just physically but
socially, economically and politically.
This was the question that Erik Conway and
I set out to answer in our book that also
has a very optimistic title, The Collapse
of Western Civilization. The book takes
place in the year 2393 when a historian
looks back on our present and asks the
question: how is it that they knew so much
about what was happening to them, had so
much good scientific information and yet
did so little to prevent it. The year is
2393, the occasion is the commemoration of
the great collapse of 2093. I wanted to
read to you from the book but time doesn't
permit that. So I'll just summarize the
argument and hope that you'll buy the book
which only costs $6.95 in its Kindle
edition. So first, our historian recounts
what happened in the great collapse. It
begins with the collapse of the West
Antarctic ice sheet and this physical
collapse then ramifies into social
dislocation and the collapse of economic
and political systems. Then she tries to
answer the why question. Why did people
let this happen? And she argues that the
grip of free market ideologies combined
with scientists' failure to communicate
what was truly at stake created a
disabling paralysis. So my question today
is how do we avoid that future? The
question of what kind of future we will
have is really the question of whether we
are capable of addressing the problems
that before our eyes. And this of course
is not a new question. Indeed, I will
argue it's the Malthusian question. In
1798 as most of you know, Thomas Malthus
asked the question: can the enlightenment
project work? By that he meant can we
reasonably expect to improve the condition
of mankind. And his short answer was no.
And for this reason, Malthus is often
considered an anti-enlightenment
philosopher. He rejected as impossible and
even misguided the enlightenment
aspiration to achieve the perfectibility
of man and of society. He even doubted the
possibility of long term and sustained
improvement. Now most of us also know why
Malthus came to this pessimistic
conclusion. It was what he called the
positive checks. Positive in the sense of
absolutely, positively certain. And those
were the checks of famine and disease, and
the misery and mortality that ensured from
them. Now most of us also know that
happily Malthus was wrong. And it's
generally taken to be received wisdom that
the main reason he was wrong was because
he failed to appreciate the empowering
effects of technological innovation. The
19th and 20th century saw technology
enabling a number of key developments that
help to stave off the Malthusian disaster
that he imagined. The most important of
course was increased food production. But
also arguably equally important, better
public health through sanitation and
vaccination. Which led in turn to the
greater survival of children. And the
survival of children along with the
education of women and the development of
technologies, available technologies of
population control, allowed many of the
nations of the world to bring their
fertility rates down without the misery or
vice that Malthus feared. Because of this
success, because of how much technology
played a role in the development of the
western world in the last 250 to 300
years, technological success has become a
foundation tenet in many of our beliefs.
Particularly those of us living in
wealthy, industrialised, technologically
endowed nations where we have benefited
the most from these technological
successes. Indeed, our belief in
technology is so foundational that we can
name several philosophies that express
this belief. So for example technophilia,
the love of technology, cornucopianism,
the belief in the continued productivity
of technological innovation,
techno-fideism, more faith in technology
and more recently something I've been
calling disruptivism, a belief in the
power of disruptive technologies. In fact
these philosophies are so powerful that
some of them even have their own bibles.
So some of you are familiar with the bible
of cornucopianism, the book, The
Resourceful Earth. Now, one of the things
I find most interesting about faith in
technology is that it cuts across party
and ideological lines. In fact, I would
argue it's one of the few things in
western culture that does. So the
cornucopians are mostly conservatives and
neoliberals. They have confidence in
human ingenuity and the capacity of the
market place to do its magic. The
techno-fideist tend to be traditional
republicans, democrats and what I call
paleoliberals as opposed to neoliberals. I
guess we have to have mesoliberals too. We
haven't figured out who they are yet.
Techno-fideists tend to believe in
government investment and technological
R&D. And then there's the disruptivist who
I haven't quite figured out what they
believe in. But they talk about the need
for disruptive technologies but without
specifying how those technologies come to
exist. But all agree on the crucial role
of technology. What they disagree about is
how we get it. So liberals tend to focus
on education and research particularly in
great research universities and
institutions like this one and UCSD across
the street. Conservatives stress free
market economics and entrepreneurship. And
disruptivists don't say. But here's the
rub and actually there're several rubs. So
I'm a historian, there's never only one
answer. The first rub is what I'm calling
the cargo cult mentality and we have
anthropologists in the audience so I hope
they'll appreciate what I mean by this.
When you listen to the advocates of
technological solutions to climate change,
no matter of the left, or right or in
between, one is struck by the similarity
to anthropological descriptions of the
cargo cult. By that I mean we are waiting
for the goods to arrive but we have no
coherent plan to get them. To the
cornucopians I would ask: but what if the
market doesn't do its magic? To the
techno-fideists I would ask: well, what if
basic research doesn't translate into
usable technologies. And to the
disruptivists: what if the climate
disruption arrives before the
technological one? The second rub, much of
this discussion ignores what we have
learned or should have learned from
experience. It ignores what we know from
the history of technology about how
transformative technologies became normal
parts of our lives. Now I've lived with
historians and historians don't like big
generalizations. There are no laws of
history and we tend to focus on the
specifics of individual developments in
cases and cultures because we know they
are all different. But there is a
generalization that I think is broadly
true about technology in the 20th century.
And that is that none of the
transformative technologies of the 20th
century were produced either by market
based mechanisms alone or entirely by
government R&D either. Rather nearly all
the transformative technologies of the
20th century involved government-private
sector partnerships. And here's just a
short list. I couldn't fit them all on a
slide. But just some examples, rural
electrification, the development of
telephone and telegraph, aviation and air
traffic control, nuclear power, the
internet, digital computing, space
technologies, pollution control
technologies all formed by
government-private sector partnerships. In
fact, the only two exceptions I could come
up with, and being at the Salk Institute,
I have to mention the polio vaccine and
the contraceptive pill also developed
largely here in Southern California. These
were private-private partnerships but
where one half of the partnership was
philanthropic rather than private sector
entrepreneurial. Electricity is a very
well studied case in point. We know a lot
about the history of the development of
electricity. We know that entrepreneurship
brought electricity to most Americans in
major cities, but it took government
initiative to bring it to rural citizens.
And that's true in other countries as
well. In fact, most other countries have
rural electricity before the United States
did because their governments were less
reluctant to get involved and because they
viewed electricity as a common good rather
than as a commodity. The third problem is
what I'm calling the problem of
persistence forecasting. And by that I
mean assuming that the future will be like
the past. Technology has led the way in
many radical changes in the way we live,
but will it be up to the challenge of
anthropogenic climate change? The Zen
Masters have said that technology makes
major contributions to the minor needs of
man. Now, I think that might be a bit
strong. Having a warm, safely-lit house,
and clean water and good food would seem
to be more than minor needs. But still, in
the world of laptops and iPhones, one may
well wonder are we getting the
technologies we want or the technologies
we need. It's now a truism that Malthus
was wrong but the fact is that billions of
people today do still lack adequate food
and water, and they do suffer misery for
that lack. And in many parts of the world,
childhood mortality remains very high.
Life has improved dramatically for those
of us in the upper four billion as I think
Ramanathan calls it, but it remains
highly unimproved for at least two billion
of our fellow citizens. And in public
health, it's well documented that medical
breakthroughs of the past decades has
mainly addressed the diseases and even the
discomforts of the wealthy to the neglect
of many of the most devastating diseases
of the poor. So why have we made so much
progress on telephones, and contact lens
technology and cosmetic surgery, and such
relatively modest progress on solar cell
efficiency and energy storage? Well, I
think one part of the answer is clear.
Markets respond to market signals. And
without a price on carbon there's
insufficient demand for energy efficiency
and storage. Governments will respond to
political signals and those have so far
been largely lacking as well. And of
course this also explains why we haven't
solved the diseases of the poor. And the
fourth issue is the issue of inequality
and inequity. Today, technological
development has not resolved problems of
inequality and in some cases has in fact
exacerbated them. So perhaps Malthus was
right after all and technology just
brought us extra time. So will we survive
the future? Again I still think the answer
is yes. But how we survive hangs in the
balance and it will depend in no small
part on how quickly we can develop the
technologies to transform our energy
systems. And to do that we can't just sit
around chattering about disruptive
technologies or letting the market do its
magic, while meanwhile the fossil fuel
industry continues to explore for and
develop still more reserves of fossil
fuels, including the Arctic, one of
the few places on Liz's maps that's not
filled with people. And of course, we
continue to use those fuels. We have to
get past wishful thinking and
techno-fideism to apply what we know from
experience it is likely to take to solve
these problems. And that brings me to the
thorny issue of politics. People don't
like to talk about politics. It's awkward
and divisive. In fact, we've had a whole
set of wonderful speakers today but no one
has spoken about the evolution of
political systems or the evolution of
governments. But without talking about
political systems and governments, I don't
see how we can solve the problems that we
face. Now many people have seen an analogy
between our problem of relinquishing
dependency on fossil fuels and the 19th
century problem of relinquishing
dependency on slave labor. Interestingly,
some of the people who invoke the need for
disruptive technologies to solve climate
change are the same people who invoke this
analogy with the disruption of ending
slavery. But slavery was not ended because
of disruptive technologies that eliminated
the need for slaves. It was ended by the
disruptive politics that included acts of
terrorism, or illegal sheltering of
escaped slaves and finally culminated in a
tragic, bloody, military conflict. Now few
of us are prepared to break the law to
stop disruptive climate change and I'm not
advocating that we necessarily should. And
I've certainly heard many of our
colleagues criticize climate scientist
James Hansen for crossing a line and
"becoming an advocate."
Because he has been arrested
protesting the Keystone XL pipeline. I do
not know whether what Hansen is doing is
right or wrong, or whether it will make a
difference or not. And of course no one
does. But as a historian, I will say this:
most of us in the climate science arena
have been focused on science and
technology, and to a lesser extent on the
business side of business as usual. But
what may matter most, what may be most
urgent and what may actually determine the
question of how we survive is whether we
can create and sustain a disruptive
politics. Politics makes nearly all
scientists very uncomfortable. We don't
want what we do to be politicised and we
are afraid of being seen as political. But
it seems to me very unlikely that we can
solve climate change with politics as
usual. And it seems to me also very
unlikely that we can solve climate change
with our scientific thinking as usual
either. And so maybe the time has come to
think about that. Thank you very much.